the original motion is perfectly
acceptable and allows for much of the
spirit of the amendment
for example the publication of the grey
report would be automatic upon the
conclusion of the metropolitan police's
work there was no need to complicate
matters
the ukraine situation is of huge
importance
but the invasion of a sovereign nation
by a dictatorial aggressor
should not be a reason why we should
accept lower standards ourselves
i have told the prime minister
to his face that i think he is doing a
good job robustly supporting the
ukrainian government
and her majesty's government along with
our nation
can be proud of their role and
generosity
let us give credit where credit is due
however
much as though i may have tried
i cannot reconcile myself to the prime
minister's continued leadership of our
country and the conservative party
i say this by means of context so that
everyone
particularly my constituents and
colleagues can understand my position
without hiding my views with ever more
elaborate disguises
to those constituents who disagree with
me
i appreciate their anger
just as i can the anger of colleagues
however
say what you mean and mean what you say
i submitted my letter of no confidence
to our honourable friend the member for
ultraman sail west in december of last
year
i did so for the following reason
it followed the leak
of the allegra stratton
mock press conference video
in that video
i believe she did nothing wrong
she nervously laughed and sought
to make light of an embarrassing
situation
to see her crying
on her doorstep
feeling the full weight of
responsibility and anger of a country
was deeply moving
and i felt immensely sorry for her
and i say this
i hope that she is well and that she
will be able to continue her
distinguished career yeah
but what
alarmed me most
was later that evening
a press preview
of the winter covered plan b measures
brought forward
brought forward to try to move matters
on
now we debated those measures at length
but we can agree perhaps not on their
extent or their importance but they
nonetheless sought to compel or restrict
what people in this country could do
i therefore thought to myself if a
government was prepared to bring such
measures forward earlier
in order to distract from its own
embarrassment
that the prime minister was no longer
fit to govern
i care deeply about my colleagues
i know
that a number
are struggling at the moment
we have been working in a toxic
atmosphere
the parliamentary party bears the scars
of misjudgments of leadership
there can be few colleagues on this side
of the house i would contend
who are truly enjoying being members of
parliament at the moment
it is utterly depressing
to be asked to defend the indefensible
each time
part of us with us
now i have questioned my place
in this party in recent months
and perhaps that's symptomatic
of a slave of our voters in the country
but i tell them firmly i'm not going
anywhere
and i urge them
to stick with us at the forthcoming
elections
but for us to maintain
their trust and confidence
we must be seen to do the right thing
it is our responsibility it is the
conservative parliamentary party's
responsibility
we must stop delegating and delaying our
political
judgment yeah
we each only have our own limited and
imperfect integrity
we can't keep spending it on spending on
others
who we cannot be sure will not let us
down
now i have great empathy
for all of those who worked at number 10
and in the cabinet office
they bought an immense burden
and worked in the most intense pressure
they worked hard and they made
sacrifices
and i also extend that same empathy to
my writing or friend the prime minister
who knows more than most
the personal challenges and personal
battles that come that came from the
pandemic
but the matter before us
is one of the heart of this institution
of our parliament
i love this place
believing it to be a place of high
ideals and purpose
what is said here matters
quite apart from the facebook clips
about roundabouts and drains in our
constituencies or indeed the conflicted
anger to wind people up
it should be a place venerated
by those of us given the singular honor
of being sent here
now of course it can be a pantomime a
farce turgidly boring obscure
but it should always be
reasonably honest
and it is for that i hope not naive
principle
that i cannot support the amendment and
i will vote for the main motion